Next we'll talk about the difference between parent and instance materials
and how to add a few more features to those functionalities as well.
So we'll review parent materials and instance materials to begin with.
We'll talk about creating some switch parameters for instance in so you can
really dial in the result of what you want a specific instance to look like.
And we'll talk about creating a master material, a UV control for instance in.
So let's just review the parent materials and the instance in concept.
So when to use it and what and why is it useful.
So you'll see that we have parent material on the right hand side here.
We've got color value, in this example we've decided to create a metallic value
and also a roughness value and we've plugged those into the respective inputs.
Now you'll see that these are all parameters, you'll see in the
slight italicized text below it says param, param, and param,
and that essentially means it's a parameter that we can use to change
the result outside of the parent material.
So on the left hand side here you'll see an instance version of this material
and on the the top properties you'll see that we've got the albedo ticked,
we've got the normal ticked, and we've got the roughness ticked.
And we can dial in these values based on the instanced version of that.
So we've created one material here that has parameters that we can change
and on the instance we can make subtle tweaks and shifts.
Sometimes we might want to make large shifts and tweaks,
but essentially you don't have to create a material from scratch,
you can just change the values that you wanted to change
based on the parameter of the master parent material.
So we can think about adding a little bit more functionality
to these materials. The previous example was a little bit more of a basic
that you'd expect to see in any given unreal project.
Now let's think about how we might switch based on some of these parameters.
So we can import a desired texture, whatever you'd like,
and we'll prompt you at the end of this section to create your own.
So if we just go through the notes to begin with,
and then you can pause the video and try and recreate this yourself.
So you import some kind of desired material,
we'll right click and search for a switch parameter.
So if you just right click in the material graph, type in switch parameter,
you'll have a static switch parameter that will appear there,
and then you just want to select that.
And then we can create several constraints and plug them into the false node.
So if you want to create a const,
you can hold down one on your keyboard and left mouse click,
and that will create a const one.
Alternatively, you can just find the constants in the right click menu.
Scalar parameters, in a similar way,
scalar parameters are constants nodes that have been converted to a parameter.
So once we've created that const,
so we maybe held down number one on our keyboard,
we left clicked,
you can actually right click on that new node that you created
and convert it to a parameter,
and therefore you'll then be able to give it a name.
By default, it'll just be a numerical value,
but if you want it to be a parameter,
you can right click and convert that to a parameter.
So we want to convert all the texture sample nodes to parameters,
including any constant parameters,
they will now become scalar parameters for you to assign names to
that we'll be able to communicate with in an instance version of this material.
If we want to think about creating a master material with UV control,
let's maybe add a UV coordinate.
So just right click UV coordinate,
and this is a text coordinate in this example,
we want to create two multiply expressions,
so we've got one multiply here,
one multiply there,
you can actually hold down M for multiply on the keyboard,
and to create a multiplier there,
we can create an append expression,
we can create three scalar parameters,
again just holding down one on the keyboard for each one
and convert them to a parameter,
and then connect them to each texture UV desired.
Just a note on this last section here,
you'll see the comment box there as well,
but the last multiply acts as a bridge and can be an add instead,
so if you'd like to create an add instead of a multiply,
you can do that,
and it will simply shift the UVs whilst multiply shifts and increases the scale.
So keep in mind,
and it depends on the design effects of what you would like your material to look like.
To create the instance version of the material,
so we've got this new material in our content browser,
you'll see it wherever you created it in the folder,
you can actually right click on this master or parent material,
and create a material instance based on that parent material.
When you do, a new material will be created,
but it'll be a material instance instead of an actual just master material,
and we can load up this instance,
and you'll see some kind of box like this,
it'll have different parameters based on what you had created in the previous example,
but it'll allow you to tick certain parameters on and off of the properties
that you want to edit based on the material that you're trying to create.
So instances are used to prevent constant recompiling of shaders,
because we've got this parent or master material,
that's what's doing all your shader compilation,
it knows what to expect from the PBR system that you're trying to create,
and therefore every instance is just based on that parent shader.
So Unreal knows to calculate certain parameters,
and then it's just dialing in the specific result that you want.
So we can make the instance from the master material,
we can open the instance, click the nose to activate them,
swap out any textures you would like,
and it gives you a lot more freedom and flexibility,
and it's also just less performant,
well it's more performant but less heavy on performance to take this approach.
So maybe it's worth jumping in now into your editor,
maybe think about creating a new parent material with some switch parameters,
you could create the UV parameter control as we just went over in the video,
and maybe just test them out, test that workflow,
get familiar with it, it's a concept that you'll use in all your Unreal projects,
it's just a very streamlined way of working,
it allows a lot of flexibility,
and it's just a useful pipeline to know and understand moving forward.